الهجره حلم يراود الملايين في العالم
العربي حمص السكان على الاقل في 14 دوله
عربيه يفكرون في الرحيل ايا كانت الوسيله
او الوجهه وفق ما افاد به استطلاع
للبارومتر العربي عن مدى خطوره ظاهره هجره
الكفاءه العربيه العاليه يمكن ان توفرها
هجره هذه الكفاءات في المجتمعاتها الاصليه
وعن السياسات المطلوبه للحفاظ على هذه
الكفاءات في الوطن العربي
[موسيقى]
قرر انت الهجره ما هو ساهل خصوصا ان
الشعوب العربيه مرتبطين برشا بعائلتنا
وليليان العلاقات الاسريه كبيره
ممكن اي ساكن بهاي البقعه الجغرافيه من
العالم انه يشعر فيها اكيد هيدا بده يشجع
البعض على الاقل لمحاوله تامين الخلاص
الفردي
الهجره اللي صارت خلال هذه الفتره هواي
صارت يعني دول الاجنبيه بسبب المشاكل اللي
عم تصير البلدان هذه تقني نحن نطلب
ننتقل الى احد هذه البلدان انا هجرت
لفرنسا في البدايه بسببه وكان استكمال
تربساتي فرنسا قلت في السنه الرابعه من
التربسات الاقامه في الجناح العامه وكان
حلم اي طبيب شاب هو الاستكمال التربوسات
في في اوروبا من جمله العوامل او الظروف
غير المساعده اللي بتدفع عاملين بالقطاع
التعليمي للتفكير بالهجره او للهجره
حياتها تقديم ابحاث علميه عم بتضيف
للانتاج المعرفي كل واحد يمكن بمجاله او
باختصاصاته من جمله هذه العوامل ما يتعلق
بضعف البنيه التحتيه الظروف اللي مر بيها
البلد كانت ظروف صعبه انا متاكد ومتيقن
هسه اي دوله تقدمه او اي بلد متقدم اذا
تصير فيه ظروف من الظروف العراقي يصير
بنفس اللي صار عندنا بالهواء هم هجره وسفر
وهروب من البلد اغلب الكفاءات واغلب الناس
المتخصصه في كثير من الجدال اعمال
الموجوده
ادى الى زياده في عمليه الهجره فرحانين
بالوضع اللي موجود في الاقسام تاعنا في
السبيطارات متاعنا في البلوكو
بروجرام في برشا بلايس اخذت لمتجر مثلا ما
يخدمش هم شكون يقول انا نمشي للخارج
نخدم عشرين ثلاثين في المئه لمسانس نخدم
به نخدم فيه
التعليم بهذه المفارقه الكبيره يعني عم
يقدموا عوامل جذبه لاصحاب العقول واصحاب
الشهادات العاليه حتى يوفوهم لانه هن
بالمقابل بالمقابل هذه هذا التوظيف عم
بيساعدهم عام 2022
التحق ما يزيد عن الف ومئه طبيب تونسي
بمئات الاطباء التونسيين والعرب الذين
سبقوهم الى فرنسا لهذه الثوره الثروه
البشريه يعني ثوره
من الدول العربيه
ويستثمر فيها كثير ولكن مع الاسف نسلم على
طبق من فضه او تسلم على طبق من ذهب لهذه
الدول الغربيه بدون مقابل مع الاسف وهذا
خساره واضحه للدول العربيه طبعا المسافه
في المهجر في البدايه لم تكن سهله يعني
السنوات الاولى كانت صعيبه ولكن
برشا عمل كانت عندي رغبه كبيره في تخصص في
امور دقيقه وخاصه الاختصاص الجراحه الكبد
وزاره الكبد الاختزاز لدي للاسف
مهوش متقدم في تونس هناك طلب في الضفه
الاخرى للمتوسط في اوروبا عموما التي تبحث
عن مثلها هؤلاء الشباب الاذكياء المثابرين
جيدا للمشاركه في تنميتها على مستوى
المنطقه العربي في خسائر سنويه حوالي 200
مليار دولار يعني في كل سنه حوالي 100 الف
من اصحاب الشهادات اطباء مهندسين من
اصحابات اختصاصين الى الخارج وهي بتشكل
خسائر كبيره ليش لانه الدول العربيه ومنها
لبنان بيكلفوا كتير عليهم لاعدادهم
وتدريبهم وحتى يخلصوا مثلا الطبيب كل
الناس او اغلبيتهم عدم يفكرون في الهجره
كل
كل مؤهلاتهم وكل شيء يعملوه يعملوه من اجل
الهجره وبالتالي سينقص تركيزهم في بلدهم
علاقتي ببلدي انا حريص انه ما تنتهي وما
قادر اطلع منها ولا ركبان اطلع منها بتمنى
ان يكون قادر اكون جزء من شبكي من
اللبنانيين العاملين بالخارج بقطاعات
مختلفه
القادرين ربما على تقديم شيء ما لخدمه
بلدهم قد تختلف الاسباب التي تدفع اعداد
كبيره من الكفاءات العربيه الى الهجره
لكن النتائج واحده
لن تستطيع الدول العربيه القضاء عليها على
الاقل على المجال قصير يجب ان نخلق بيئه
تجذب هذه الاشخاص من دون اكراه وهذا ممكن
اول شيء علينا الاقرار انه المنطقه لا
تستوعب كل الاشخاص اللي عم يتخرجوا منها
وبالتالي في جزء من المهاجرين لا بد من ان
يبقى مطرح ما هو لا يمكن للمنطقه ان
تستوعب كلها هؤلاء المهاجرين ان يعودوا
اليهم لو الامكانيات تتحسن في المستشفيات
اغلبيه الالف اللي هجروا بشقائهم رجعوا
لتونس وتتحسن الوضعيه السياسيه والمناخ
السياسي والمناخ الاقتصادي في البلاد
ممكن يكون
عنايه كثره ولا طفره كبيره في
الاطباء
الاستفاده من التقدم والتطور العلمي
الموجود في الخارج ونقل هذه البرامج وهذا
التطور الى البلدان مثل لبنان او سوريا او
غيرها